[Music]
many neuroscientists and philosophers
argue that there is no such thing as
free will
some even claim experiment has proven
this to be the case
yet the behavior of these same
scientists and philosophers appear to
assume their own freedom say when
formulating and promoting their own
theory
to avoid this paradox should we accept
that free will is an illusion
and as a consequence cease to praise our
children when they do well and refrain
from punishing murderers when they're
caught
or the denial of free will a mistake
driven by the desire to avoid a profound
conflict
with the scientific assumption that its
laws alone govern the universe
let's meet our three speakers helen
steward professor of philosophy of mind
and action
at the university of leeds is known for
her work on the metaphysics of mind and
free will
including her influential 2012 book a
metaphysics for freedom
patrick haggard is the professor of
cognitive neuroscience at university
college london
he's a leading researcher in
neuroscientific research into free will
having held positions at yale and oxford
university and won the jean nico
prize for philosophy of mind dan dennett
is perhaps one of the most famous
and controversial figures in philosophy
today his groundbreaking work includes
the books
darwin's dangerous idea and
consciousness explained
and he spent much of his time arguing
tirelessly for an atheistic and
naturalistic view of the world
we're going to start with a three-minute
introduction
uh by each of the speakers let's start
with helen
is the denial of free will a mistake
thank you very much for that
introduction um
so what i would want to say to begin
with
is that the answer to the question
whether the denial of free will is a
mistake is
is the boring philosophers one that it
does depend what you mean by free will
i say that not just because i'm a
philosopher but because it is the right
answer
um i think there are some conceptions of
free will
that are what i think are the sort of
mad conceptions
uh mad conception of free will for
example would be the idea
that you sort of have to make yourself
from the ground up from scratch
by choosing all your desires and your
values and your principles
this is about of nowhere um i mean
that's obviously a conception of free
will that that no one could satisfy in
fact it leads to an infinite regress
because
it makes no sense to choose things like
desires and values and principles
except by reference to some further
desires values and principles
and so you could re-raise the question
and so on and so on
so not even god could have free will on
that conception of free will
um so that's the first thing i want to
say there are mad conceptions i don't
want to be defending any of those
the question then remains are there any
conceptions of free will which which are
worth defending
um but uh that aren't mad in that sense
and i think the answer to that is yes
and that's what i'm going to be trying
to argue this evening
the conception that i want to defend is
a conception which is opposed to what i
think of as a very bottom-up way
of thinking about the human agent what i
mean by bottom-up
is an idea of the human agent where the
agent's doings
his or her actions are entirely
determined
uh by the mechanistic interactions of
say
a chemical or electrical kind uh of her
small parts you know things like neurons
cells we could go even lower talk about
molecules and so on
that reductive conception of the human
being is one i want to insist we have
absolutely no reason for science or
anywhere else
to endorse and that's going to be my
position this evening
patrick your opening statement is the
denial of free will
a mistake i think from a scientific
point of view you might want to start
with the phenomena
and for me the phenomena that need to be
explained to actions so
people make actions i think we generally
would agree with that and these would be
things like
pressing a button or signing your name
or even pulling a trigger but
the question then is where do those
actions come from and my approach
coming both from neuroscience and from
psychology is what you might call
reverse engineering of actions
so an action is the contraction of a
muscle why does the muscle contract it
contracts because
particular neurons in a brain area
called the primary motor cortex
fire and then why do those neurons fire
will they fire because
neurons in some brain areas just
anterior more frontally
to the primary motor cortex they fire
and you can keep looking back and saying
well
what's the causal chain here but what
you don't ever find
is anything mystical or anything
exceptional
and what's quite interesting in fact is
that modern neuroscience
doesn't now view the brain as a linear
causal chain
going back to some uh
imagined first cause which uh
you know you might think of as free will
rather the brain works as a loop
so the real cause of the action that i
make now
is the combination of two driving forces
one is the brain's representation of the
wide context in which i am so the brain
human brain in particular is able to
integrate an enormous amount of
information
and bring it all to bear on the action
that i make now
so this perhaps explains the appearance
of complexity
behind human action and the second
really striking feature about human
action
is that the action that i make now
depends on what you might call history
but i think i would prefer to call
memory
the previous experience that i've had of
making actions in the past
so there are lots of actions that i know
are really appropriate in one context
because i've learned that
but are really not appropriate in
another context because i've learned
that too
so i think what this means is that all
of these
events which lead to the astonishing
behavioral repertoire that humans can
perform
the the range of things that i can do or
that you can do at any one time
is staggeringly wide compared to most
other animals
but it's all still due to brain activity
and as far as we know all of that brain
activity
amounts to chemical and electrical
events
which obey the laws of physics which
obey natural laws so there's nothing
there's nothing exceptional there's
nothing as it were strange
and in that sense i think i would
definitely like to agree with helen
that we can we can reject exceptionalist
ideas of free will
instead i think what we need to do is to
account for the
the range and diversity of human action
but we can do that within completely
mechanistic
conceptions of brain science
dan your opening statement is the denial
of free will a mistake
yes it is but i think actually i agree
with just about everything that both
patrick and helen said
um the big mistake
beca comes when people confuse control
with causation
yes everything that happens everything
you do is caused uh
determinism is just not the issue let's
for the as it were to worst case
scenario it
let's suppose that the world really is
deterministic
um well then we can't flip coins can we
oh yes of course we can
and aren't coin flips caused yes they
are like everything else
but they aren't controlled the thing
that coin clips have been designed to be
an action
with readily observable uh results which
can make a huge difference to how things
go but they can't be controlled
that's that's the point of a coin flip
and the same thing is true
interestingly enough of our brains
people like patrick do wonderful
experiments but in order to do an
experiment
you have to clamp
the uncounted millions
of degrees of freedom to get the subject
to do just one of two things then
if you establish that sort of control if
you impose
that very narrow channel on that brain
then
indeed you can sometimes predict up to
10 seconds ahead of time which choice
the person will make that's interesting
but it doesn't shed any light on the
reality
of the kind of free will that's worth
defending as helen says or worth
wanting as i've said the kind of free
will it's worth wanting
is the kind that normal human adults
have when they're not being manipulated
and there there's a real
threat facing us right now uh
our autonomy has been uh
outstanding up to now but new techniques
not so much
of of tampering with people's brains
but tampering with their minds which are
their brains but tampering with them
by misinformation and uh
subtle disinformation which
tends to turn us into puppets
where we think we have more control than
we do
that is the danger it's a real danger
but what we have to learn is not that we
might as well give up because we don't
have free will
what we have to learn is how can i
protect the autonomy that i have
from those agents
and it's all those agents who want to
control me
the weather doesn't want to control me
gravity doesn't want to control me
they're not agents
agents are the sources agents are
controllers
and uh autonomous agent is a
self-controlled agent
right so we seem to have a lot of prima
facie agreement here let's see if we can
drill in a little little more and
uncover some areas of disagreement
let's start by talking about the
implications of science on this old
philosophical question so we've talked
about
uh causality being built right into the
methodology
into the the theory and practice of
science um
that has long been taken as a threat to
the idea of libertarian free will
on top of that experiments have shown
the labet experiments for one
that our actions are decided by our
brains before we have the conscious
experience of deciding
to take these actions so does science
for either of these reasons tell us that
free will is impossible
can we start with patrick to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you